c'est un peu toute votre histoire ça
c'est à dire en fait vous faites des
gros tubes formidables que tout le monde
a encore en mémoire et parallèlement
c'est obscurcit un peu votre carrière de
réel chanteur compositeur sur des choses
un peu plus sophistiquées
alors Philippe vous êtes né le 26
septembre 1945 à Fort-de-France en
Martinique sous le nom de Philippe
Durand de villejegu du Fresnay aux
parents sont des Antillais blancs des
becquets dont la famille s'est installée
dans les îles depuis 1750 donc un truc
comme ça
on a retrouvé des ancêtres à cette
époque là vous savez d'où il venait en
France alors dans la région nantaise et
de Bretagne votre père exploite des
bananeries au village du François vous
habitez et votre mère est l'héritière du
rhum Bali ouais famille riche alors pas
du tout non pas du tout ce que j'avais
un grand-père qui était espèce
d'humaniste
un bonhomme qui avait qui a créé le
vieillissement du Rhum en fût de chêne
c'est lui qui a mis ça au point au début
du siècle dernier il a filé dessus des
copains il a eu 10 enfants on a revu ces
livres de contes c'était dont un machin
pour exercice il a fait les petites
sœurs d'épaule et petit frère des
pauvres donc c'est à type l'argent
n'avait absolument qu'une importance
pour lui alors en France très joli dans
une petite maison en coloniale cernée
par une luxuriante végétation tropicale
à 6 km de la route la plus proche on a
vécu dans cet endroit là un peu comme
des des Robinsons quoi alors là vous
pêchez les écrevisses vous montez à
cheval enfin une vie de rêve ouais on
apprend à chasser avec des des
lance-pierre j'ai un souvenir incroyable
de cette époque là alors votre mère qui
chante est bien avait rêvé d'une
carrière artistique et sur les conseils
de Louis Jouvet qu'elle avait rencontré
lors d'une tournée de Jouvet aux
Antilles pendant la guerre elle était
venue en Métropole en 1945 mais elle
s'était tromper de métro il n'avait
jamais eu le rendez-vous qui aurait pu
la conduire vers l'art lyrique elle
s'est trompé de métro et je pense
qu'elle était déjà un peu amoureuse de
mon père et puis quand je suis né ça a
été un enfant tellement difficile et
sa voix était très abîmée et vous en
fait vous êtes un peu devenu chanteur
par à tavisme vous vivez un peu sa vie
par procuration d'une certaine façon
mais je m'en suis rendu compte un jour
en fait si c'est bizarre que tu es perdu
ta voix et que j'en ai fait mon métier
alors pendant votre enfance je vous
écoutez de la salsa sur Radio Cuba et
des musiques antillaises sur les radios
en monde moyenne qui avait là-bas à
l'époque c'était la biguine c'était les
vieilles les vieilles mélodies les
magnifiques mélodie créole qui font
partie du patrimoine les grands
orchestres du père d'Edy Louise par
exemple et la radio diffusait aussi du
jazz beaucoup de jazz et de la musique
classique mais en 1960 quand vous
débarquez en métropole vous découvrez le
rock n' roll j'entends les premiers à
l'idée j'entends des premiers
chaussettes noires qu'est-ce français et
puis les Beatles tout de suite les
Beatles les Stones crimes voilà dès que
j'entendais un truc qui me branchait un
peu je l'achetais donc c'est comme ça
qu'un jour je viens l'album de crime et
puis cet album c'est devenu un album de
chevet quoi l'album culte que j'ai
toujours d'ailleurs par la suite c'est
dans un pensionnat dans la Drôme adieu
Luffy que vous êtes initié à la musique
par votre prof d'anglais qui n'est autre
que Grimal Wright
à l'époque prof il nous expliquait
comment
pourquoi le pourquoi des choses tiens ça
c'est une jolie phrase musicale pour ça
pour ça et ça c'était vachement
intéressant c'est comme voir un match de
rugby avec à côté de Jean-Pierre rive
quoi
là vous achetez une guitare vous rêvez
de devenir chanteur mais vos parents
vous collent 3 ans dans une école de
commerce où vous montez des groupes
quand même hein j'avais monté deux on
avait monté deux groupes on faisait les
alors c'était bien on faisait des
kermesse on faisait des soirées
mondaines
mes hommages madame tout ça en smoking
c'était assez rigolo et puis on jouait
pour pour nous pour rigoler alors vous
sortez un premier 45 tours en 1969 qui
s'appelle à la califourchon les
militaires quand ils allaient en
permission à Fort-de-France ils étaient
dans des dans des camionnettes de
l'armée et puis tapait comme ça sur le
la camionnette machin et faisait à la
Cali à la Cali à la calife Auchan mes
amis c'est watts
ça veut dire je vais la sauter quoi je
vais je vais me trouver une gonzesse et
je vais la démonter c'est un peu ça
l'idée alors quand je suis arrivé avec
ça en France
les gens ont trouvé ça rigolo hein mais
en même temps mes potes antillais disait
tu es quand même gonflé de comme gonfler
de dire ça je dis c'est pas grave bon
après ça il y a eu ce fameux groupe
science supers Crew qui avait fait
Angela en caisson Chua pendant papa ce
qui veut dire Angela je vais te défoncer
pendant que ton père n'est pas là et
tout ça c'est passé à la radio
alors le deuxième c'est sur une musique
de Billy Bridge avec les filles je ne
sais pas ça ça marche bien deuxième
succès bah je comprends pas d'ailleurs
ce qui m'arrive en fait parce que
c'était pas le genre de chanson avec
lesquels j'avais envie de me faire
connaître quoi pour moi ça a été un coup
ça voilà le problème c'est que vous
pensez plus à vous amuser qu'à bosser
c'est l'époque où vous fréquentez
Caroline de Monaco qui a 17 ans à
l'époque je me suis jamais exprimé à
propos de Caroline de Hanovre maintenant
Monaco pour deux raisons la première
raison c'est que j'ai fait le serment à
son père le prince Régnier la seule fois
que j'ai vu que jamais de ma vie je n'en
parlerai
donc je m'y tiendrai je continuerai à
m'y tenir on m'a proposé de l'argent
pour écrire un livre j'ai dit non
beaucoup d'argent j'ai dit bon la
deuxième c'est que nous avons tous les
deux fait nos vies que nous avons des
enfants et que je pense que le passé des
parents pour des enfants
je sais pas à moi de d'ouvrir ma gueule
donc
l'amour de jeunesse un bel amour très
joli une histoire
merveilleuse délicieuse charmante voilà
je le garde que ce souvenir formidable
quoi alors l'album suivant ne marche pas
vous partez de chez vea vous êtes obligé
d'auto-produire vos 45 tours c'est la
galère et là devant l'échec de votre
carrière vous envisagez de changer
d'activité de retourner à la Martinique
vous achetez un aller simple
je l'ai toujours je crois et avant de
partir vous misez sur un titre écrit
avec Didier Barbelivien il tape sur des
bambous
c'est le tube de l'été un million et
demi d'exemplaires vendus
garde ta voiture garde ton appart gare
de ta chaîne stéréo
déchire ton billet chez toi rembourser
ton billet voilà ce qui se passe et il
s'est passé énorme un truc énorme ouais
sinon vous auriez fait quoi en
Martinique si vous étiez retourner je
sais pas moi j'avais envie de lui faire
du tourisme
bosser faire un petit hôtel depuis 20
chambres espèce de vie d'ailleurs
peut-être que je la je ferai ça demain
j'en sais rien alors trois ans plus tard
nouveau tube avec Barbelivien elle
préfère l'amour en mer énorme musique de
film je faisais un album à l'époque qui
s'appelait nonchalance pendant qu'on
enregistre l'album Michel langue me
demande une musique pour un film qui
s'appelait à nous les garçons j'avais
des chansons d'avance et je lui fais
écouter ça c'est un truc qu'on avait
depuis des années qu'on n'arrivait pas à
parler quand même fou j'appelle
Barbelivien un jour à 7h du soir je dis
Didier demain matin 10h j'ai besoin d'un
texte sur
ella elle a lalala ça s'appelait comme
ça et là elle a la la le lendemain il
m'apporte le truc je chante
je fais deux prises de voix je retourne
jouer au flipper avec Eddy Mitchell qui
était dans ce côté
les Costa vient de faire les voix 4
heures de l'après-midi c'était bouclé
j'ai repris mon truc l'enregistrement de
mon album
quand la musique du film est sorti il y
a une attachée de presse de jeunes CESU
qui a dit c'est un tube qui est allé
voir les radios c'est devenu un tube et
puis en même temps cette chanson je lui
en ai voulu à mort parce qu'elle m'a
flingué mon album qui venait derrière
elle c'est un peu toute votre histoire
ça c'est-à-dire en fait vous faites des
gros tubes formidables que tout le monde
a encore en mémoire et parallèlement
c'est obscurci un peu votre carrière de
réel chanteur compositeur sur des choses
un peu plus sophistiquées je pense
ça commence à me gêner énormément là
j'ai quand même inventé le frisbee j'ai
des il y avait toujours des très jolies
pochettes sur les singles qu'on faisait
Jeff Dunas qui était un photographe
américain de charme qui m'avait fait la
photo des bambous Jean-Baptiste Mondino
etc
donc belle pochette donc les mecs
gardaient les pochettes et ils m'ont
envoyé le disque en général je prenais
les règles donc jamais au bout d'un
moment c'est un peu gonflant
deux ans plus tard collé-serré Jocelyne
Béroard voilà encore pareil la chanteuse
de kassavait énorme tube j'appelle ça
des moments magiques c'est la chanson
l'écoute
on peut l'écouter 20 fois dire c'est
vachement bien on la chante une fois il
y a les espèces de chair de poule qui se
machin et on s'est dit si je la chambre
pas je suis un gros con donc je vais
aller voir Jocelyne j'ai dit écoute il
faut qu'on fasse ça on a on l'a fait
alors grosse célébrité à ce moment-là
qu'elles ont été les réactions de notre
entourage par exemple votre mère elle
dit quoi à ce moment-là j'ai la chance
d'avoir eu et d'avoir toujours une
famille
qui pour qui la célébrité l'argent le
succès tout ça
quand je suis à la maison on me demande
de changer des ampoules de
descendre les poubelles de mes petits
neveux me sautent sur les genoux et voit
pas la chanteuse quoi il voit juste un
oncle ou un grand-angle avec les médias
c'est toujours bien passé non jamais de
problème non jamais si on m'a fait un
moment de mon divorce je crois qu'on
avait fait une page dans Voici mais bon
ça m'a rien de non non
vous avez gagné de l'argent il y a pas
mal d'argent vous avez mis de côté non
j'avais mis de côté j'avais mis oui
évidemment j'avais mis de côté dans
j'avais une famille donc on avait acheté
deux biens enfin en tout cas un bien et
moi un petit peu d'un autre bien mais
comme beaucoup de couples j'ai je me
suis séparé de ma femme et puis à un
moment il faut il faut privilégier les
enfants souvent les enfants sont
le pognon après tout j'ai jamais couru
après ça non plus quoi c'est pas
l'argent mon père n'était pas un homme
d'argent mes grands-parents n'étaient
pas des gens d'argent
quand j'en avais j'en avais quand j'en
avais pas quand j'en ai pas j'en ai pas
je m'en fous et alors question amour ça
évidemment ça devait être formidable non
parce que vous êtes séduisant ça devait
être vécu des très jolis moments c'est
vrai
le 83 à 95 j'ai été marié et une
fidélité
réciproque
immuable c'est à dire que comme j'ai
l'habitude de dire un peu vulgairement
même pour 50 balles au bois de Boulogne
jamais quoi quel était le meilleur
moment de toute cette époque Philippe il
y a un moment 88 qui a été pour moi
extrêmement important c'est le jour où
on avait fait l'Olympia tout seul quoi
tout seul pendant une semaine on avait
loué et mon père est venu le jour de la
première
il était au deuxième rang et il m'a il
est venu me voir dans la loge après il
m'a embrassé il m'a regardé et ce jour
là j'ai compris dans son regard qui me
disait mais tu as quand même bien fait
de te battre pour arriver à faire ça
parce que voilà il est mort un an après
voilà donc il a eu le temps de me dire
que j'avais eu raison bon moment et le
pire moment de toute cette époque je
crois que c'est en 97 lorsque je me suis
retrouvé exemple
je faisais 58 kilos avec une une minerve
des oxydants cet accident là
le les deux plateaux de la balance le
moral qui était qui était par terre le
physique qui était par terre et une
adversité
qui était difficilement supportable quoi
là ça a été quelque chose de je pense
c'était quelque chose de terrible et
quelque part je me demande si c'est pas
plus mal parce que c'était j'allais
tellement mal
que je me suis dit si je sors pas de là
je vais pas pouvoir me regarder dans la
glace vous êtes nostalgique aujourd'hui
de cette époque non non
parce que j'en ai d'autres sous le coude
bon j'en ai fait d'autres et puis chaque
fois que je fais une chanson je me dis
ah nostalgie le matin pas quoi le passé
c'est le passé et si c'était à refaire
votre vie qu'est-ce que vous ne referiez
pas pareil je prendrai un avocat pour
mon premier contrat
je pense que ça m'aurait évité cinq ans
de 5 ans de presque d'interdiction
d'aller en studio donc ce qui m'a permis
de faire des chansons d'en faire
beaucoup beaucoup mais je pense que je
j'ai fait confiance je ferai peut-être
moins confiance à des gens qui fois
c'était comme ça que ça se passait aussi
à l'époque donc c'est ce business ouais
c'était le showbize c'est pour ça que je
déteste ce mot là le jour vous allez
mourir qu'est-ce que vous voulez qu'on
écrit sur votre tombe
pas si mal que ça le mec
merci très heureux de rallumer la
lumière soit merci beaucoup Thierry et
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de Inna
larditude abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu